Sahil Kapoor joins us he's a national
political reporter for Bloomberg News
good morning to you all right so here's
the bottom line no matter at ik wig
party whatever it is right I mean if the
economy is strong a president generally
is reelected or elected if economy is
not strong they're not so the question
is how each party how the president and
then Democratic candidates are adjusting
their message now to a potentially
shifting economy right it's always been
the case that the economy is enormous ly
important to presidents in terms of
reelection and especially so for this
president because his approval numbers
are weak and the economy is the main
thing holding him up to a level of in
the low 40s and if that goes the bottom
could fall out so looking forward I
think the economy the state of the
economy is gonna be the single biggest
predictor of the election outcome just
think about it over the last century the
only three presidents who have been
elected and lost reelection have done so
because of a recession somewhat of an
unexpected move this week with a White
House announcing it would delay the
tariffs on China to December 15th what
are your sources telling you about that
there's a lot of nervousness I mean many
of the president's allies and advisors
want him to abandon the trade war
entirely they don't like it they believe
that it's American consumers and
businesses that end up paying the cost
but the president's in a box because he
did campaign on getting tough on China
and if he backs off that pledge then
there's a different kind of political
price to pay and also obviously the
impact on the economy and Jeff mentioned
Democrats so with all of this when it
comes to the trade war but also the
economy and a potential recession which
some say may be out there how are the
Democrats using this right now there's a
bit of a schizophrenic message from
Democrats in the trade war they're all
over the place they know that they
oppose what President Trump is doing but
they're centrists in the party were Pro
trade who want to cut more trade deals
who like NAFTA and the TPP and then
there are others like presidential
contender Elizabeth Warren who wants to
move in a more restriction Asturian
Trump even so there's a split within the
party and I think that presidential
primary will help sort that out let's
talk more about the gun debate now and
how Dayton and El Paso may or may not
have shifted that debate what's next in
Washington well the house the
democratic-led house has already passed
two bills mostly to strengthen
background checks earlier this year when
they come back from the August recess
they're planning to pass more
legislation on this front the
republican-led Senate has not moved and
there's no indication yet that they will
there's
discussion about that the president has
shown some interest in doing something
but they will only move that there's a
clear and consistent and emphatic push
from the president there is so it's more
on the Republicans in the Senate right I
mean because the president has indicated
that he's open to at least the universal
background checks right but the
Republicans in the Senate also know that
after Parkland President came out for
raising the rifle age to 21 and some
other gun control measures and then
backed away so they're looking at that
and they're cursing well will we be left
at the altar again okay the NRA has also
been pretty quiet up to this point the
eternal issues that they've been having
is that having an impact on maybe the
role that they're playing in DC or how
much weight they're carrying there to a
point but the bigger issue is that the
politics of gun control in this country
have changed very rapidly in about a
30-point direction in favor of stricter
gun laws since the Obama presidency and
this is driven by the suburbs mass
shooting after mass shooting after mass
shooting has turned college-educated
voters soccer moms more and more in
favor of gun control and I think this is
where my Republican sources are
expressing some consternation about can
they hold on to the suburbs if they
don't show any interest in doing
something about this issue so he'll
Kippur thank you thank you